you disrupted the leadership campaign
disrupting the mayoral campaign you
should be Prime Minister everything
they've left the centre the parties have
been captured they're not coming back
how can two parties possibly do justice
to what modern Britain is that sort of
sense of people wanting a disruption is
palpable I think I've seen outside us go
up in flames because they haven't had a
clue how the political system and
politics actually work as an
entrepreneur when I started out I got
nothing but nice things happened to me
politics is completely different I can't
say anything nice about it it is
literary of vibe business political
disruptors are tempting voters away from
the UK's two big main parties
competition is fierce with would be
radical options on the nationalist right
and even on the centre ground Britain's
politics is being shaken up and the
result of December's general election
has never been so uncertain the 2016
brexit vote exploded the usual
left-right alignment there are now at
least four parties battling it out one
of the insurgents the brexit party is
led by Nigel Farage whose lifelong dream
for the UK to quit the EU may be about
to come true I'm Rex it's throw it all
up in the air because that went beyond
left and right and the political parties
haven't known how to react to a major
political decision that didn't fall
under party lines the other challengers
want to stop brexit but they also hope
to capitalize on the upheaval some form
of tumult was probably inevitable in
British politics because whenever you go
through big societal change
you see tamil professor jane green of
the british election study
and measures the UK's changing voting
patterns we went to Oxford to ask her
how Britain went from this to this from
the 60s
through to today we see more people
switching their votes between general
elections over time so a much more fluid
volatile picture
so does this volatility mean that it's
kind of fertile territory that there are
opportunities there for the political
disruptors you've got a very available
electrics you've got opportunities for
the political parties what you've also
got is loads of uncertainty you can see
there's a disruption going on and we
don't know where it's going to land
Claire Fox a libertarian from the left
was elected as an MEP for the brexit
party earlier this year as voters
deserted both labour and the Tories of
course change is always unpredictable it
makes it scary
so is democracy but to argue against
disruption on the basis of things worked
completely misunderstands that for many
people they didn't so we've talked a bit
about things being more up for grabs
yeah I'm going to try and ask you to
explain where the voters might be do you
think about one dimension of politics
from left to right and within that kind
of left-right bread-and-butter economic
kind of way of seeing the world lots of
people have left a sense of views lots
of people have rise to centre views but
the majority of people would be in the
middle and therefore it makes politics
very much about that kind of center
ground about competing for the majority
of voters Britain has always been about
understatement compromise pragmatism and
I think that's where the energy is I
think it resonates deeply Rory Stewart
is leaving Parliament
he's left the Conservative Party he
wants to reinvent moderate politics by
standing as an independent candidate for
London Maire I think actually the UK's
traditions are much more consensual much
more designed for centigram politics
than almost anywhere in the world
that dimension is still very important
to vote choice now but of course we've
all started seeing the world
predominately through the lens of brexit
a brexit isn't about bread-and-butter
left-right issues on the whole it's
about this different dimension that
cross cuts the left-right dimension it's
divided the party and it's divided the
voters a lot of people who thought of
themselves as center ground in the old
politics in the new politics are far
from Center ground chakra Munna walked
out of labour earlier this year
attempted to start a new anti brexit
centre party change UK but is now trying
to redefine opposition politics from
within the pro-european Liberal
Democrats those guys are no longer
centigram they are firmly on the liberal
internationalist open anti-authoritarian
side of the new dichotomy so when people
say to me I want a return to gov centre
ground policy I'm kind of like but
you're no longer Center ground you're
actually firmly on one camp political
scientists like you are used to thinking
about voters in this rather more
complicated way in the past we think
about it in terms of people that have
more socially conservative views and
more socially liberal views but also
we're now thinking much more about
people that have anti-immigration views
and also pro-immigration views and also
anti-european more brexit supporting
leave voting views or more pro-european
and remain supporting views and so we
have the impression that politics has
become much more polarized both the
brexit party and the radical remainer
are betting that politics is now about
the values there's different fault lines
on there so what's happened is rather
than saying the big decision in British
politics today is whether we nationalize
the railways it's actually our attitudes
of popular sovereignty so you ask me the
question you know where is the space
yeah where's the opportunity so on the
one hand you know we talked about kind
of important so if this this issue
becomes less important and we might
worry about left-right again but what if
this issue so it doesn't become
important but at the current time it
feels and looks in terms of the evidence
that people are pretty divided if you
look at some of the people who've been
running our country some of the
decisions we've made in the last decade
or so you go how is such a brilliant
country in this mess
Simon Franks once a committed Labour
Party backer is dismayed by this
polarization he's been spending time and
money trying to use his startup skills
to shake up Center ground politics the
mission was to scope out initially is it
possible to create a new political party
that could win in one electoral cycle
can you in politics do something that
kind of maps entrepreneurial ISM on to
party politics yes you can but not in
the center if you're on the wings of
British politics so in fact any politics
and you have a cause you can mobilize
people incredibly quickly to bring about
a change because people are so desperate
for that change or believed so strongly
in that cause in the center it's much
harder to do because by definition you
should be more balanced more reasonable
you understand that no one issue is
going to make our country completely
better or completely worse Joseph Lynch
believes in the power of the middle this
Austrian academic helped start a
successful new party and has written a
book on how to make it work it's bloody
hard it's bloody hard for politicians
these days the political itch to be
scratched is that many people feel not
represented anymore and too many of them
then decide to vote for populist sand
nationalists but I think many of them
would actually like to have a choice to
vote for something different and
constructive the primary reason why
change UK didn't succeed in the way that
we would have liked it to is as you said
I'm not sure people were looking for
disruption in as much as they were
looking for their politics to be
properly represented but they weren't
let's be Precious about the vehicle
through which you do that and to try and
create something new in a
non-presidential system is nigh on
impossible in a sense you can't just
compete on ones I mentioned people want
to know where you stand so if you're
competing on this dimension but you're
divided on this dimension because you've
got parties for
the left parties from the right then
essentially okay fine so you've got this
bit sorted out but are you able here on
the left or are you here on the right in
terms of where your voters are likely to
be I think the most important thing is
if you want to build a centrist
alternative that you're actually early
on are starting to talk to the voters
and start to interlink what I call
islands of discontent most political
startups will fail I think that's not a
problem I think actually many many need
to try for some of them to succeed once
you've broken the habits of a lifetime
at the European election obviously
everything got thrown in the air then
you're not quite that we always vote
labor in our family we always vote Tory
in our family anything could happen it's
like when MPs we're bail against a whip
right once they get the taste for it it
becomes possible again even those people
is saying let's get brexit done their
argument is let's get brexit done so we
can go back to normal and I think they
underestimate the appetite for a much
more fundamental shift and nothing's
ever gonna go back ever the problem is
that the government of the center has
always seemed terribly sort of
bureaucratic and inert it doesn't really
seem to listen that doesn't seem to
engage which gives people the idea that
maybe there's a silver bullet maybe
there's some fantastic thing and it's
some counter ideology for a person like
a hand grenade you can chuck at the
system and blow the whole thing's gonna
blow up and sunny it's all gonna be much
better so there's no messiah coming near
the Colima son I mean I think I'm also
you definitely we've had conspicuous
examples of success on both the left and
the right I'm thinking of Nigel Faraj on
one side and probably Labour's momentum
on the other but there's this whole
space in the centre with lots of
plotting lots of activity of activity
but it's really hard to make something
happen it's a much easier message so
Nigel Roger I think is a brilliant
communicator and I think and I don't
have this disregard that so many people
seem to have I think he speaks for a
large community of our country about
issues that no one else will talk to I
think the same on the Left
Jeremy Corbyn gets on the stage and says
capitalists all bad people the reason
why your life isn't as good as you'd
like it is because of that bunch
over there and some people they go the
Messiah's arrived no one's got a
monopoly on grievance in the wake of the
crash in the wake of austerity in the
wake of globalization you know taking
away the Securities of people took for
granted the question is of what you do
about that we've completely failed to
produce a product that's really exciting
I mean none of these third parties sent
a party leaders that she worked out how
to produce something that really makes
the public thing well okay all right
actually I'm not going to vote the way
that my parents voted this election is
not the end and I think the most
important thing to know is this
elections been called a very peculiar
circumstances but I personally think
that the genies out the bottle and that
what we are likely to see in the next
five years is a very disrupted political
scene in the first winter election for
decades the established parties are
being buffeted from all sides there are
wide open spaces in the political
landscape an enormous potential for
storms to come if you had to put money
on it would you bet on political
insurgence either a smaller party or a
new party trying to replace or split one
of the two main parties if the two
mainstream parties adapt their positions
working out kind of you know where can
they attract the majority of voters then
it's very difficult it's still very
difficult for minor parties to break
through in normal times I would say that
it's impossible to actually get a new
party in the UK Parliament but we're not
in normal times we're past normal times
and I think therefore don't give up hope
there might be something on the way we
can probably do better if we think about
it to redesign our political system
really great our parties maybe create
some new ones maybe look at our voting
system look at the way we select MPs
look at where we treat mp's anyone who
believes that everything goes back to
normal is kidding themselves
[Music]
you